hallo mein name ist luca und meine liebe
luxury wette kann sich doch der ein oder
andere von euch an ein video von mir
erinnern was ich vor zwei jahren hier
auf meinem kanal hochgeladen habe das
ekelhaft man ja wann interessantes spiel
was ich da gespielt habe und wer diesem
spiel ging es darum dass wir das normale
leben eines menschen durchleben müssen
also wir werden erst geboren dann will
kommt irgendwann die liebe und dann
müssen wir uns auf pickel ausdrücken so
alle sachen die das leben halt so mit
sich bringen zum abschluss des spiels
ist man dann am ende gestorben und
daraufhin kam eine einwendung dass man
sich auch mit den zweiten teil anschauen
könnte und zwar heißt dieses spiel
afterlife und das habe ich jetzt noch
zwei jahren tatsächlich mal gefunden
von daher würde ich sagen klicken wir
direkt auf layer hier und mein gott was
da für die musik plötzlich also wären
wir wieder die gleiche bescheuerte musik
die wir auch beim ersten teil schon
hatten hier steht holt das heißt so
[Musik]
ich muss
hey
ich habe nicht verstanden was ich machen
soll
random optical
ok anscheinend bin ich in diesem spiel
ein geist jener des petit petit
kompliment das mir viel zu schwieriges
englisch einfach auftragen im anschluss
steht wieder frei das heißt wir müssen
hier gedrückt halten
wenn ich ich kann das ding halt auch
nicht steuern ach ich muss es los lacht
da war wieder ein baum im weg
also ich halte das singen wieder ein
bisschen gedrückt und gehe jetzt relativ
vorsichtig vor um hier unten haben wir
den brunnen da darf natürlich auch nicht
ist eine ernste frage ja es kann doch
nicht so schwierig sein körper das ding
darüber zu fliegen also in letzter zeit
ist es ja auch auf einem kanal sollte
sich immer mehr so im spiel
ok wenn es hier geschafft hier um mond
herum hier unten steht wieder ein baum
als ich habe keine ahnung was hier so
das ziel des spiels ist wenn ich hier
nach rechts fliege seht ihr schon bin
ich hier beim mond jetzt will ich
schwarz oder was protektor gott noah
scheiße protect yourself [ __ ] hier
steht diesmal dreck also ich muss mich
umziehen und ich glaube ich darf nichts
you came to protect your wife vom danger
[Applaus]
aha das ist meine frau weiß ich mich
noch recht an den ersten teil erinnern
kann wie gesagt das ganze zwei jahre her
ich glaube allerdings dass es da der
fall war dass ich vor meiner frau
gestorben bin dementsprechend meine frau
noch lebt und sie ist eine seniorin und
ich bin ein geist muss sie beschützen
vor den gefahren die halt so sich
tummeln in der welt hätte hier steht
jetzt noch so lonely anymore also wie
wir beide sind jetzt tot wichtig
trotzdem mal auftragen protect ich
dachte schon wir müssen von vorne jetzt
wieder anfangen also ich muss jetzt
glaube ich hier alles weggehauen ja klar
fliegende ja wo kommt das jetzt auch
noch scheiße unten igel der da ins bild
fliegt genau genug kommt jetzt steht
hier revenge dreck und das ist auch zeit
ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll
was soll ich machen
was solche machen durch einfach die
scheiße hier wegziehen oder was
erst das okay das wäre es tatsächlich
sinnvoll gewesen wenn ich den ersten
teil kurz vor diesen teil nochmal
gespielt hätte in dieses komplette video
beruht auf dem ersten teil den ich
bisher hochgeladen habe bevor ich hier
draufklicken möchten wir noch mal ganz
gut zum teil hier verlinken irgendwo
also dann könnt ihr euch den theoretisch
noch mal anschauen und dann könnt ihr
euch das hier anschauen und wissen wovon
ich rede
bleibt jetzt einfach dran und wir machen
erstmal dieses level hier weiter hier
ist jemand der auf seinem stuhl sitzt
und 51 ad freddys spielt ich klicke
jetzt einfach mal hier drauf ach ich
muss ganz ganz doll hat draufklicken
meine fresse alters
cooles spiel ich musste jetzt
aufschreiben klicken
das heißt ich musste wieder drauf
drücken ich weiß nicht was ihr der sinn
davon ist ob ich den sieg ich finde das
ding halt nicht mal gruselig aber was
ist denn die scheiß im challenge ter man
sich da stellen muss ich klicke hier die
ganze zeit drauf ich klicke die ganze
zeit jetzt nicht kommt trotzdem die
kacke oder ich muss wirklich ganz ganz
ganz ganz toll drauf drücken gott ich
habe es geschafft ich musste einfach nur
noch schneller draufdrücken boards green
phase wird ferner wird tritt kiju jack
poole tableaux expecting
okay das war nicht so lustig also ich
muss die ganzen anderen geist zum lachen
bringen möchte ich einfach mal auf jack
und dass man wieder falsch also ich
denke jetzt einfach mal auf dem pult
table und das war dann wohl die richtige
antwort ist die difference between
snowmaker des no woman no border collie
mexican training in michael maze what
the [ __ ] clumsy synco dem szenario
klingt also alter diese echt nicht so
schlecht wie spies produce milke bombis
your mom oder bubis die sind ich so
kacke what do you got no wax cloud klar
wir haben den witze preis bekommen und
jetzt partytime freunde ich muss hier
drauf drücken so wie ich das anscheinend
hier richtig sehe also hier viermal blau
13 und hier nochmals zwei mal grün
einmal lila und jetzt die ganze zeit
hintereinander blau grün blau lila jetzt
wieder blau grün blau grün grün grün
lila blau lila blau grün blau 2000 jahre
später
best night at the championship angesagt
und wir müssen hier beer pong spielen
ich werfe den ersten mal so das hat mir
beer pong lehre immer gezeigt immer von
oben rein werfen dann gehen sie immer
rein genauso
das hohenloher 41 zack ist auch wieder
reingegangen ja genau wahrscheinlich
geht der dollar jetzt in ganz langen
hier rein und hinten das ding versenkt
der typ müsste noch einfach mal nicht
treffen
also ich sage auch wieder rein
ich bin champion jetzt müssen wir uns
anziehen für irgend so einen ball oder
so was anscheinend mich ziemlich mal so
an
ja und das hier jetzt wieder auf zeit
ich weiß nicht was wir hier ein sammeln
sollen
ich glaube wir müssen hier rüber und
hier runter und dann zur schokolade noch
weiter hier oben auch noch einen sachen
einsammeln ach ich glaube das sind wir
selbst jetzt verkleidet hier an
halloween oder keine ahnung was eck
kommen
das müssen wir hinkriegen kommt also ich
habe nur noch so wenig zeit kommt sagt
nein noch was also wieder das hinkriegen
no shit freunde es ist so krank
schwierig dieses ding zu steuern weil
der immer so richtig weit weg schlittert
dann wieder nach vorne
ok jetzt müssen wir sortieren
ich glaube dass hier ist gut das ist gut
das ist gut das ist nicht schlecht
das wanne millisekunde also diesen haben
wir auf jeden fall richtig gemacht und
auch in der zeit richtig hingekriegt ja
sehr gut daumen hoch passt auto alter es
ist wirklich also viel komplizierter als
das erste spiel der balles durch das
heißt wir müssen jetzt hier lang hier
hoch jetzt wieder hier runter hier hoch
jetzt wieder hier runter hier hoch
glaube ich hier ausländer wo mein gott
ich bin gar nicht mal so schlecht gerade
freunde also jetzt hier lang warten
hierdurch zu erwarten hier durch hier
unten lang hier oben her und jetzt raus
hier
ich habe dazugelernt nun können wir uns
entscheiden zwischen dem highway to hell
und stairway to heaven heimlich gehst
jay tue heaven ich glaube jeder will in
den 80
muss immer da draufdrücken und ein
gegner stufe hoch oder eher alter das
sogar das dann spiele ich nenne das
beschreibt dieses spiel einfach komplett
also letzte stufe freunde wir sind oben
angekommen und welcome to heaven
das war's wenn es geschafft zeit läuft
ab
das ist der eingang zum himmel und wir
haben geschafft
[Applaus]
hey ich feiere diese kurzen spiele das
erste spiel von denen namens life hat
mir auch schon mega mega gut gefallen da
haben alle von euch haben die kommentare
geschrieben heimspiel unbedingt auch mal
afterlife ich glaub das video habe ich
genannt ich sterbe weil ich am ende
sterben und das video hat auch über zwei
millionen aufrufe bekomme oder so daher
wollte ich unbedingt jetzt auch mal
endlich den zweiten teil davon spielen
namens afterlife ich hoffe euch jetzt
gefallen wir uns das getan hat las gerne
einen daumen hoch bei diesem video hier
da und schreibt mir gerne und in die
kommentare
ob ihr noch weitere von solchen spielen
kennt also irgendwie so stumpf lustige
zeichentrick dikmen spieler oder sowas
in der richtung habe ich früher ganz
ganz viele hochgeladen darauf hätte ich
mal wieder mega bock aber ich habe
irgendwie alle schon gespielt auch diese
webos und fliegende komplett die linke
diamonds und sowie habe ich alles schon
gespielt aber falls sie da noch was
kennt schreibt scannen und die
kommentare und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]